[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition in this video were
breaking down the boy to the first film
had some very mixed reviews but
personally I enjoyed it and I found the
twist to be a fun one that stuck with me
long since seeing it clearly the movie
had a following too as the sequel was
quickly pushed into production initially
it was supposed to be released in July
last year however for whatever reason
the studio decided to push it back was
there a good reason for this or does the
studio have a hit on their hands well
throughout this video we're going to be
breaking down the film and giving our
thoughts on its plot and ending there
will be heavy spoilers here so if you
haven't had a chance to see the movie
yet and don't want anything ruined then
I highly recommend that you turn off now
without the way I just want to give a
huge thank you for checking out the
video now let's get into our breakdown
of the boy to
in contrast to the first film the boy
too delves highly into the supernatural
and where the prior movie explained
everything away with the story of a man
who lived in the walls of a house this
dives deeply interview cult the movie
centers around Lisa played by Katie
Holmes her husband Sean and their son
Jude initially Jude is at that point
where he's too old to be sleeping with
teddys but after a traumatic home
invasion that he witnesses the boy
becomes a mute his main method of
communication becomes a notepad and Lisa
suffers from violent dreams due to a
head injury that she gained during the
attack Jude has regressed into a shell
and with his mother's mental state
collapsing life becomes difficult the
home invasion is a really interesting
way to start the movie and not to give
too much away but it's probably the
scariest thing in the film for me I
always find the idea of someone breaking
into your house at night to be far more
terrifying than ghosts and ghouls and
this is also clearly the case with Lisa
who can't escape the horrible thing that
happened to her in order to get away and
hopefully fix their problems
the family decides to move this sends
them to the guest house of the he'll
ship property which is set on the
grounds of the same location as the
first film whilst out in the woods they
come across the main manor and do
discovers the doll brahms buried there
after digging it up it becomes the main
form of communication for the boy and
like the first film brahms begins to lay
down the ground rules of things that its
friends can and can't do
slowly Jude becomes obsessed with it
dresses like the doll and ends up
referring to him as a person I don't
know where the kid got the suit but I
wish I had one like that growing up he
looks very dapper brahms becomes more
and more aggressive but Lisa can't
really tell whether it's Jude lashing
out and using the dollars an excuse or
if the doll really has a sinister side
to it due to her brain trauma
Lisa sort becomes an unreliable narrator
and because of a head injury
we can't tell what's real and what isn't
she apparently begins to hallucinate and
the doll becomes more and more of a
fascination for her as we see it slowly
take over the child Lisa looks up the
history of brahms and discovers the
backstory from the first movie from the
houses ground keeper Joseph played by
Chris Finch bloody good rep they learned
that the Brahms from the first movie
killed the little girl and
lived in the walls of his house as we
know the hill shoes went on to commit
suicide and Brahms then went on to haunt
grete and become attached to her now
where Brahms his arrival was a big
reveal in the first film we learned that
the character died off-screen and that
it was actually the door behind the
entire thing and not the other way
around
so yeah if you were expecting a big
return from Brahms then you'll be
disappointed to know that he's dead and
doesn't come back for the movie Lisa
discovers that Jude is planning to kill
her and a husband and Judes cousin is
severely injured after bullying him Lisa
manages to trace Brahms back through all
of his owners and she uncovers a pattern
of murders carried out by young boys
that state the doll made them do it now
my biggest problem with this is that it
negates the first film's ending I know
that a lot of audience members were
disappointed in the first movie because
it didn't actually have a supernatural
element to it but personally I like the
subversion that had put on a thing that
we'd already seen a hundred times before
I feel like this film will annoy people
like myself who enjoyed the first movies
final half-hour and the retconning feels
like they're trying to capture the
audience that they should have with the
first however in doing so they stick to
the cliches that the boy avoided and it
results in this being regulated to your
standard affair that we've seen done to
death
Joseph goes to the house one night after
things have escalated and ties Lisa up
he reveals that Brahms made him put him
back together and leave him there for
the family he's been helping the doll
and his regarded as crazy by the locals
Jude was an easy target because of the
trauma that he faced and he pays lip
service to the sacrifice that Brahms
will make him carry out to align his
soul with him Lisa manages to get away
from Joseph and she goes to the main
house and discovers dude there wearing a
Brahms mask and apparently about to
carry out a ritual Lisa lies and
promises to you that they will all go
home and take Brahms with them as a
member of their family and Shaun arrives
and smashes the dolls head in which
reveals the true face beneath it this is
a demonic and sinister looking creature
and this is what has been controlling
Jude and all of the boys before him the
dog kills Joseph by raising him in the
air and throwing fire from the furnace
towards him Jude then picks up the doll
in order to calm it down and say that it
will all be alright at the last second
Jude tosses the doll into the fire
burning
in the process it seems like the curse
is finally over and the family returns
back to their home I have no idea how
they managed to move back in no problem
as none of them seem to work but on the
surface they go back to how things were
before the attack that opened the film
however we learn that the ritual was in
fact successful and that bronzes spirit
has entered dude the ending of the film
with the sacrifice was just a charade
carried out by the doll in order to make
it seem like Jude had managed to stop it
it killed Joseph because he was the only
person that could uncover the truth and
reveal that the doll was still alive and
it now has finally left the grounds of
the house the film closes with Jude in
his room pulling out the Brahms mask and
putting it on saying that they will be
together forever personally I believe
all of the moments in the movie in which
Jude tried to plead with his mother and
talk about how Brahms was controlling
him have all turned out to be a ploy and
there is a lot of reasoning for this due
to the attack from the opening of the
movie Jude realized that his parents
weren't strong enough to protect him
from the real dangers of the world and
thus he ended up becoming an introvert
that was scared of his own shadow
naturally he gravitated towards Brahms
who would protect him from everything
and this made him stronger in the film
as lip service paid to the fact that
Brahms is in some ways a security
blanket for Jude and I think this is a
literal depiction of the character and
what he represents for the young boy
Jude is of course in a vulnerable
position and like Joseph said he will be
safer than he's ever been because of the
dolls protection Brahms too reached out
to Joseph because he was too isolated
and alone and clearly the doll reaches
out to people in a similar position we
know that he plans to kill Lisa and
Shawn and this will likely happen after
the events of the film and thus Brahms
will be able to operate without anyone
knowing what's really going on with the
character I don't know if we will get a
sequel for the film but there are
certainly things that could happen with
a story and the boy going forward before
we get into the rest of the video I just
wanna let you know we're giving away a
free copy of the infinity Saga to one
random subscriber all you have to do to
be in when the chance of winning is like
the video subscribe to the channel and
leave your thoughts on the film in the
comment section below
the one it's gonna be chosen at random
on the 15th of March in this up be
shipped out from then to ever gets the
price it's the best
everyone he takes part okay so as for my
thoughts on the film I'm sad to say that
I was really disappointed with this as
one of the two people that actually
liked the first movie
I was expecting a bit more from this but
I feel it will alienate the both of us
that enjoyed that film and people who
were expecting a more Haunted doll story
will still be bored by how Road the
pieces this is not a la ta that the
movie excels in and I would have loved
to have seen a focus on the home
invasion and how that psychologically
affected Lisa and made us see things
that weren't there from here we could
have had the original Brahms return and
live in the house similar to the first
film and I think the idea that a home
invasion victim was questioning whether
they were going through another home
invasion would have been far more
interesting paranoia is a great driving
force in horror but it's just missing
from this film when it seems like the
perfect opportunity to discuss it
unfortunately the movie misses the mark
in several ways for me and though I'm
sure many might have fun with it
personally it fell short of my
expectations unfortunately Brahms the
boy to you gets a 4 out of 10
now obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the boy too and if you agree
or disagree with my score comment below
and let me know and if you enjoyed this
video then please give it a thumbs up
and make sure you check out our video
from yesterday in which we break down
everything you need to know about the
upcoming season of Westworld we talked
about the plot trailer and a lot more so
it's definitely worth checking out if
you want something else to watch you
want to support the channel from as
little as 99 cents a month then please
click the join button below
yeah access the content early and can
suggest video topics and breakdowns we
massively appreciate it and it goes a
long way telling videos like this get
made you want to come chat to us after
the show either follow us at definition
wide see click the discord link in the
description below those are the best
ways to keep up to date with heavy
spoilers so hopefully we see over there
very soon
this is a channel for people who are mad
into movies so if that's the kind of
thing you like it subscribe huge thank
you for taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best and I'll see you next time take
care peace
[Music]
you